[Music]
more than 6 million people in the U.S
live with Alzheimer's disease a local
group a resource Group here in Henderson
is providing support to them to those
here in southern Nevada about 50 000 and
their caregivers Lauren degretty joins
us live from the Henderson
multi-generational Recreation Center to
talk all about it and give some tips so
you can take advantage of now we've got
a lot of locals here who are struggling
with the disease Lauren tell us more
yes good morning Sherry this is just one
of several resources here that these
ladies here put on first off I'm joined
by Carrie Bauer and April Grimaldi to
talk more so Memory Lane Cafe really a
providing a support services tell us
more about why why you saw for the need
and the goal yeah so Memory Lane Cafe is
a great resource for individuals who
have dementia and their caregivers to
come out and to be able to socialize
learn educate and have fun we have
activities games arts and crafts for
them to do so it's a great great area
for them to come together be around
other individuals who are like-minded
who are going through the same situation
so it just gives them a place of comfort
and to enjoy themselves thank you for
that and April one of many resources
talk about some other things coming up
here yep absolutely we have the health
fair coming up that's going to be Friday
May 12th here at Henderson
multi-generational Center from 10 to 1
and then we'll be having another one
November 3rd which is also Friday from
10 to 1 so come out and join us again
again all happening right here in
Henderson at the recreational center
yeah perfect
um and then as far as again how people
can get involved here and join you up
you guys
um they can reach out to us either by
phone at
702-660-1140 or
702-670-1810 or our website
multigenmods.com or live2ignite.com
thank you so much ladies and again if
you missed any of that we've got thank
you we've got that information on our
website 8newsnow.com for now live in
Henderson Lauren negretti 8 News Now